das ist neu seit 1.4 mit samen mit den
körnern halte ich habe ganz viele samen
man empfiehlt genau 111 holz stein sap
sap portal
obwohl das müssen wir dann eingeschickt
jetzt kämpft doch schon sagen damit wir
noch ein bisschen abschätzen kann also
die gesagt ich wäre eigentlich für
zweieinhalb stunden welcher part
eigentlich relativ justiert also ich bin
ich brauche noch ein bisschen was ihr
fertig zu bauen
ich bin als legal dich fragen wir jetzt
gar nicht du musst halt machen
ok jetzt ist mein haus dabei für eine
demo dings nicht tabu ist drin
in meinem haus nur noch zwei eier also
zwei eier jetzt hier im spiel
die ich wegwerfen kann so ich brauche
dingsda hallo franz nicht
was hat ihr einmal was was wollt ihr
nicht verraten ja ja ja die sind diese
gut aber die sind hatten sie noch mit
offen klatschen alle den kartoffeln
gegeben
nein die kartoffel gegen jetzt wissen
sterben weil in unserem vertrag
gebrochen
ja und ich habe endlich alle das töten
habe ich dabei ich habe ja gar nicht
wofür es blöd ich fange ja auch mal
leute eh was ist mit dir habe ich
eigentlich gar kein thema den
anschuldigungen auf der tour ausschluss
kann ich ja noch gut ein thema von
silver piranha silva piranha ein thema
was denkt ihr zur schönheit und die
verschiedenen ansichten von schönen land
muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
was er schön findet man verschiedene
geschmäcker manche leute sagen immer
total scheiße und ich muss man sich
denken
die ganzen anderen urteilte wir kleiden
uns richtig beantwortet eigentlich schon
in seiner frage beantwortet was findet
ihr von schönheit was die jeder anders
sieht oder ja das halte von
schönheitsidealen achso von
schönheitsidealen also es wird ja
wirklich oft gesagt ich dachte das jetzt
mal einfach so ich mache das irgendwie
mal das nächste mal dürft ihr zuerst
wird er wirklich oft gesagt oder es wird
bzw wir teilweise immer noch gesagt das
sehr dünn schön ist damals im
mittelalter war es natürlich so dass er
dickliche frauen schön waren
deswegen wurden die auf bildern so
dargestellt und als schönheitsideal
festgestellt da wollten alles ein
bisschen zu die figur haben mittlerweile
ist es so viele jugendliche denken ja
okay ist models die sind sehr dünnen
diesen war ganz wichtig ich will jetzt
auch mal richtig werden gibt es
verschiedene sachen aber ich würde
einfach sagen jeder soll sich das selbst
herausfinden und sich nicht wegen ihrer
wegen der schönheit quer nicht an jeder
mensch ist so schön wie er ist alle
menschen sind schön kann ich jetzt mal
einfach zu sagen
und am schlimmsten ist ein mensch wenn
er das von innen heraus ausstrahlt und
sich selber schön film nicht ja das
denke ich auch nur ein frage die auch
die ausstrahlung der mit der
selbstzufriedenheit zusammenhängt ist
eigentlich das entscheidende
wenn man sich selbst nicht wohl in
seinem körper führt dann wird man das
auch nach außen ausstrahlen und das ist
dann auch kein ich glaube das wieder was
anderes was weiß ich auch dass das nicht
gut und böse yin und yang
das muss dann auch ein schwarzes
einklang sein achtes spaß ich sagen
wollte das ist ja auch so dass man
meistens so dabei frauen so die stehen
dann den laden im klamottenladen seien
beim shoppen und denken sich arbeit das
kaufen das ist schön hat aber wenn sie
sich selbst nicht wohl fühlen sage ich
mal dann bringt das besonders viel sage
ich mal wenn man etwas anzieht weil man
wieder berührt nur weil das zb andere
haben oder weil sich models anhaben weil
man doch irgendwie cool sein will dann
bringt das nicht wenn man sich darin
nicht wohl fühlt das ist immer so eine
sache
als ich hörte man ein paar schafe weil
wir haben zu viele ich muss wirklich nur
noch ein dach bonner bin ich eigentlich
durch die farbe hört sich gut an und ist
der erste gast der das wirklich schafft
gut sein dass sparkassen fast geschafft
aber du bist der erste jedoch ohne
beschweren schafft so habe ich mich
wieso wir geben derzeit und dann hat er
es ja auch geschafft eigentlich
er wollte noch inneneinrichtung als
nacheinander
ich mach das habt ihr leder zufällig
wir sind dabei hier eine kuh form
aufzubauen hat immer weiter weg laufen
ja ich bin beim bett ich bin auch im
bett ich auch endlich gut in einen neuen
tag starten stock trinken also den augen
schauen willst dann kannst du kurz hier
gucken wird schon recht alt
du hast das dach bauen solche gar keine
ahnung
no idea like it all
hast du bois duell flachdach flachdach
dann ist das so steinig macht doch aus
aus dem kabel stones labs also du mal
was macht dieses gebrannte kabel
store.de fertigen ganzen diese normalen
carlsson als lab ganz mein kapitän als
lab und damals das dach machen sie nicht
schlecht dass löwen also entweder ich
mache das oder ich mache dieses woher
haben überhaupt die ganze level bekommen
luca gefühlen oder durch höhlen und ich
denke auch durch farben oder abbauen
also ich hab 31 level sogar 31 jahren
ich hätte jetzt auch schon so viel gab
bestimmte bleibt bin ich bevor ich werde
ich das dnt gestorben dann hätte ich
auch alle verloren
letzterer reifen
du hast keine tiere merkte ich alles
geschlachtet und seine positive
landschaft ja wir haben irgendwie voll
wenig warum habt ihr wirklich will dass
ihr noch eine hühnerfarm machen haben
wir doch wo das team eine leder nappa
leder nicht hühner hat ja es 42 flint so
sind die heime oder die schüler sind ich
habe aber wieder dahin geführt hat ganz
genau kennen gar keinen eingang
doch die haben eingang von anderen seite
und den pionieren hastig braucht erde
für die farm weil das ist ja was für uns
alle und ich habe bisher nur meine
ganzen rechner fertig habe gut weil ich
habe bisher alle meine sachen dafür
verbraucht für die dinge schauen wir
bitte wirklich in die kiste auf
jugendlich 12 leder weil ich zwei habe
da kann ich wenigstens zwei bücherregale
machen statt eins zu schaffen
wieder kann man gar nicht so richtig
planen doch noch mitfahren
das ist neu seit 1.4 mit samen mit den
körper halte ich habe ganz viele samen
hallo hallo klaus aus meinem haus
allerdings wartet das problem nicht
leder ja ganz bisschen vielleicht durch
einen 2 stück rausgenommen da kann ich
mir zwei bücherregale machen solange du
den nicht wieder mein eisen klaus
einbrecher nicht mehr
alles da alles aus eigener tasche wird
aufgeräumt scherze alles ist ein holz
meter wieso das kein holz meter ich
brauche ich verstehe diesen cache
ich bin mir im zocker mode geworden
die bleibt da auch weihnachtstanne
weihnachtsfeier
ich bin schon hier im weihnachtsfieber
genau die ganze supermärkte mit letztens
noch gesehen vor ein paar tagen die am
sportplatz ihren gut weihnachtsplätzchen
was sind eure lieblings
weihnachtsplätzchen vorrätig das können
wir also als kurzes thema fürs ende
machen
schott thema schon thema meine lieblings
sind wir konsens finden den tieren trend
hin wenn ich nicht natürlich kennt ihr
vielleicht weisen jetzt finden heißt
diese ich will das mal ganz gut etwas
etwas länglich mit schokolade ist
eigentlich ein lebkuchen aber ja ja die
kenne ich die kenne ich ja die macht man
die schilder die bilder wikipedia meine
kraft wiki bilder piller cholera ich
finde ich habe zwar kein fachmann zu
googeln saft wasser
printen sind richtig lecker bei ich
liebe schokolade haare die sowieso da
kommt die schüler drucker zu einem
hinlaufen er das sehr gut was hast du
gesagt er kommt die hühner sogar zu
einem hingelaufen das ist ja gut 66
alles klar ich hab's gefunden ich weiß
wie die jetzt gehen also wir sind euer
lieblings gepäck spekulatius alter wie
auf der noch vor der pubertät also rio
ist zwar das ist nicht der blick aber so
eine art das ist das ist so eine
haselnuss keks der aus zwei dinge hat in
der mitte ist eine ziemlich lecker damit
letzten von oreo kuchen gebacken
er schmeckt nicht so gut wie fix modell
sein wer selber im haus also ich auf
jeden fall nicht bock hat ja ich hab
ganz clever vorbeilaufen sie nur gesehen
gesehen
vielleicht ist er wieder was unternehmen
weiterhin ich da vielleicht eine kuh
töten
nein nein ja doch einige ich glaube ja
ok aber her wie viel leder bronze denn
ich frau noch einen leder dann habe ich
ein buch regal und dadurch also im
software drei leder geht wofür brauchst
du machst du ein bücherregal
man brauch für bücher jetzt allein leder
der profiboxer bücherregale den
einrichtung mein haus hat mir die man
für enchantment links benutzen können
wer da freuen wir den ihn aufnehmen aber
dann haben wir auch jeder allein
verlassen schnell zwei kühe getötet nur
leder ich lasse sie seien
richtig glücklich hier lukas kopp ist
erde
rosanna rocci hast du kb kappel kannst
du dir das meine gäste unten ein steak
nehmen den rest brauche ich nachher
selber weiße christliche profil abgeben
der notfalls vergleichen was damit
wenigstens das dach fertig machen kann
mir aber auch in der umgebung so viele
höhlen oder so teile von höhlen da
kannst du die rechte oder so noch
steintreppen und zu brauchst du noch die
treppen treffen kannst ja die bauteile
für die das ist so blöd ich muss mich
bei einem nein sagen wenn du grund hat
wenn du komplett bei mir runter geht's
nicht so dass unten noch keine treppen
sind die habe ich mich für die mühe
gemacht das war das knie aber da hab ich
mit einzige rauskam sinne des vereins
treffen der 16
du hast mich jetzt auch sehr ich habe
jetzt den ton raum voll ist mit leder
kann man auch diese rahmen machen wo man
tun kann
ja und wisst ihr was man machen kann
hart sein man kann im multiplayer geheim
ton machen also schon seit 1.3 mit
diesem mit diesen ob die ränder ton weil
er könnte ja nicht darauf zugreifen
das heißt natürlich meine tnt reichen
natürlich auch mal der aktuellen album
rein noch nicht aber man kann müssen
aber dafür erst jemand wie ob sie ihre
nachbarn können sie die an sie die an zu
finden ist relativ einfach was
eigentlich genau was sie wollen halt
jemand